hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts comprehensive genomic
and transcriptomic analysis of a CRO
melanoma a past towards therapeutic
development presented by dr. Winnie Lee
on assistive Professor integrated cancer
genomics Research Institute
collaborative sequencing center director
scientific operation teachin we are
excited to bring you this educational
webcast
presented by lab reads the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning I'm julissa Meraz of lab routes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window then type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge so and don't just look on the
screen icon located in the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or you can use the
Q&A button and let us know that you're
having a problem this is an educational
webinar and this author is free
continuing education credit after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage this follow the
process of obtaining your credit please
join me in welcoming dr. Winnie Lee Jung
I will now turn the presentation over to
her in welcoming
you're winning hi so today I'll be
presenting you it was with a study that
we performed and that was funded by the
melanoma Research Alliance as well as
stampd cancer and so the title of my
talk today is comprehensive genomic and
transcriptomic analysis of equal
melanoma a path towards therapeutic
development so before I begin I did want
to highlight that this study was really
built around a collaborative model and
so we had multiple institutions involved
in the study and the success of the
study really relied on this
collaboration so I did want to highlight
that we have clinical partners at the
Vanderbilt at Vanderbilt University as
well as in the Morrison Kettering and
they provided it really well annotated
and clinically phenotype samples for
analysis the samples were provided to
Tegan where we performed next-generation
sequencing as well as subsequent genomic
and transcriptomic analyses finally as a
result of our studies there was
orthogonal work that was able to
basically be spearheaded from our
original research and that was performed
at the University of Arizona and it's
lost Mayo Clinic in Arizona and so again
while this is a data and bioinformatics
topic again this wouldn't be possible
without having high-quality samples as
well as a number of different
collaborations so just to give some
background on a crow melanoma
this is a rare subtype of melanoma and
so when we think of melanoma we often
think of the athenaeus form however
equal melanoma occurs in only about two
to ten they comprised of only about two
to ten percent of all melanoma cases in
the United States it's actually it
occurs more predominantly in
non-caucasians but it is also the only
form of melanoma that occurs at the same
rate across multiple races compared to
cutaneous melanoma a girl of melanoma
has a worse prognosis as we'll see in
the following slide in terms of what we
understand about things like that may be
associated with causing the
disease there is no obvious association
with exposure to UV light which is known
to be a factor for us a susceptibility
to cutaneous melanoma in addition there
aren't any other family history or other
environmental factors that have been
known to be associated with this form of
melanoma in terms of what we know
genetically Upendra nama CLE about the
disease we have observed and some
pulmonary work that there is low
frequency of B Rafi 600 mutations and
approximately 15% of Agra melanomas
theirs as well as about 10 to 15 percent
incidence up KITT mutations as well and
for the most part the majority of cases
are a triple wat type meaning that there
is a wild type B Rafi 600 and rath and
also nf1 James again historically most
of the analysis that's previously been
done in April melanoma has been limited
and it really wasn't until this years
until we performed our study that we
were able to get really do a full
comprehensive analysis of melanoma in
addition to our study there is also a
publication published by dr. Nik Hedberg
in Australia also perform whole genome
sequencing and that publication knows
that came out this year as well but
overall because of our limited knowledge
of the disease our goal now is to
understand better understand the disease
without the DNA and RNA levels so that
we can identify improve treatment
options for patients so looking at a
survival as a previously mentioned equal
melanoma has is associated for survival
compared to cutaneous melanoma you'll
see in the left graph that the lower
line the blue or dotted line is
reflective of eco melanoma and survival
is shown across at the bottom as well as
the percent of patients who are
surviving and so for both of these
graphs both of the lower lines on both
graphs are reflective of April Mel and
other patients and you'll see that
compared acute aeneas melanoma survival
is much worse and so again this REM
besides the
to better understand the disease that we
can identify and develop improved
therapeutics in terms of what we know
about mutation burden there has been
multiple studies that have worked across
different melanoma subtypes and the bar
graph on the left you can see that with
regards to burden of coding mutations
I'm a girl melanoma falls somewhat in
the middle compared to other subtypes
including cutaneous mucosa you love
melanomas with a mean of about 272
mutations if you look like a structural
mutations by subtype which is shown on
the right hand graph again you'll see
that a girl melanoma Falls sort of in
between other both the mucosa on the kid
Hania subtypes with a mean of about 80
structural variants so just summarizing
the workflow for this study again this
is a collaboration among clinical sites
as well as T Jenin and other
collaborators as well and so at Memorial
Sloan Kettering and band awreeoh this is
where patients were seen by the doctors
on the study they diagnosed the patients
performed a biopsy and also did analysis
of the biopsies the samples were then
forwarded over to Lou T Jen where we
performed extractions of DNA and RNA we
performed library preparations and then
next-generation sequencing on the
Illumina platform from there we
initiated our an analytical pipeline
that was developed in-house and
performed analysis across both the core
part and at the level of individual
patients so going back again to the
clinical site that was involved in
collecting all the samples again this
was at Vanderbilt and Memorial
sloan-kettering and what was really
fantastic about this collaboration is
that they maintained out really well
annotated clinical database as a result
we have robust clinical and pathological
data associated with all the samples
that we received them that were
sequenced so we were able to receive
fresh frozen tumor specimens for each
patient as well as a match to normal and
so overall we see samples from 16
patients
Vanderbilt University in 18 patients
Memorial sloan-kettering so overall we
had 38 total samples collected from
across 34 patients so looking at the
breakdown of samples that we received
received about 15 primary tumors 16
metastatic tumors and we had a few
patients for we received either multiple
metastatic lesions or either a
metastatic lesion and a primary lesion
from the same patient and again we had
34 unique patients for which we have
detailed clinical information as well as
clinical follow-up and this is just an
urban view of the the patients that we
had sequence again there was 34 total
patients but for two patients we
sequenced two tumors each and for third
patient as shown in green we sequence 3
total tumors so again we did have very
detailed clinical information associated
with each patient and so at the time of
the study we input this information into
an internal instance of sabato portal
and so I'll just walk through some of
the different annotations that we have
just to show the level of detail of
information we have associated with all
about patient samples so we have
information such as location of the
primary thickness of the primary tumor
as well as stage of a presentation
across all patients some other features
that we have is a primary depth if
there's primary alteration and the
number of lymph nodes that were impacted
across all patients and we'll see that
as you can see in the the pie chart on
the lower right that 22 patients out of
34 had positive nodes
characteristics that we captured include
the rate by race see but the majority of
the patients are Caucasian in transit
status meaning which is really a
reflection as to whether or not the
disease is spreading as well as age at
diagnosis we also have metastasis of the
status as well as overall survival
status for all patients as well and so
looking at the distribution of stages
across the patients that we analyzed the
majority or our stage two or three with
only about one stage one and less than
five patients from at stage 4 disease
so overall the Kolkata patients were
advanced stage looking at survival of
the patients in our cohort the media
over overall survival was 86 months in
the medium follow-up further survivors
were at about 36 months and looking at
overall progression-free survival
we had a median progression-free
survival of approximately 18 months with
a follow-up for progression-free
survival at approximately 25 months so
looking at the experimental design that
we implemented for the study we used an
approach it's essentially using three
different sequencing modalities - most
comprehensively capture as much
information as we can from both DNA and
RNA in many studies they've been moving
towards using a targeted approach where
you're not looking comprehensively at
the whole exome or whole genome but we
do think that limits us and our ability
to do discovery work and so we took a
very comprehensive approach to our study
and so the first modality that we
implemented it was paired terminal
multiplex I'm sequencing using the
agilent v 5 or CTR bates
and this enables us to help capture
low-level mutations and heterogeneity
samples of another approach that we also
implemented was using long insert whole
genome sequencing across pair to my
normal samples and so this was an
approach that we developed here at ijen
and what we do using this approach is
essentially triple the size of the
insert that you're asleep
saying and in doing so we triple our
ability to identify breakpoint in that
region as a result this is a strategy
for looking for structural events such
as inversions large deletions and break
points as well as this can be used to
look at copy number changes as well and
so we don't sequence these genomes as
deeply as the exomes it's usually around
the order of five to ten X for average
sequence coverage but the physical
coverage is much higher because of the
length of the inserts and so it's
typically in the order of 30 to 40 X
physical coverage we also perform RNA
sequencing on samples and so this
enables us to perform detection of RNA
fusions but we can look for if there is
any skewed allelic expression associated
with any mutations we identified because
to perform differential expression and
as well as pathway analyses and we have
also been using it to run our new
antigen and analysis pipelines as well
so just to give an overview of the
analytical pipeline our sequencers are
talking they talk directly to our limb
system in the lab and one sequencing is
complete we kick off the scale
conversion to generate fast queue files
and these are fed directly into our DNA
and RNA pipeline which all fall within a
single pipeline following an analysis of
both DNA and RNA we generate Ambridge
VCF which would be insert into a
separate server where we annotate all
the the variants with things like the
team name many descriptions or any
prediction algorithms as well as
population frequencies so looking more
closely at the DNA pipeline there's two
major components to the pipeline the
first shown here is relatively probably
well known as salvaged across other
institutions I also do sequencing in
houses we perform the linemen using bwa
we do we perform marking duplicates and
sweating use of a card we also do joint
and L realignment and also recalibration
using ket k so the resulting bam file is
used for variant detection and so we
have three different
primary analyses that are done in this
pathway the first is looking for point
mutations and spent in Dallas the small
in Dallas and so we use three separate
tools these include a new text storage
dropped on because we use an ensemble
approach we do require that the event is
called by at least two of these three
tools to reach a list of variants of
interest we also have internally
developed tools here at taejun for
looking at copy number and also
structural variant detection so here's a
high-level view of the RNA pipeline it's
not too dissimilar from the DNA pipeline
we use star for alignment of data we
also use Picard for marking duplicates
and sorting as well as gatk for record
alignment and b calibration of the
resulting Pam the band is used for
further analyses and so we use top hat
for detection of RNA fusions
we use cuff Devon DC to or for looking
at differential expression and we also
use gatk and Sam tools for looking at
allele frequencies of mutations so here
the metrics that were generated we
sequence just over 16 high output V free
flow cells on the Illumina platform and
this encompassed over 47 billion total
reads and so in in sum we had generated
over 3.8 carry bytes of data and so the
data output and the number beads are
generated for each factor of analysis is
shown at the bottom
and you'll see that our cue 30s for each
of those different sequencing modalities
are all greater than 86% so one of the
first analyses that we can pull or
perform after doing sequencing is
looking at tumor cellularity and this
can be estimated using allele
frequencies after we perform SMB
detection and you'll see that for the
most part that this tumor cellulite
areas across the samples are relatively
high probably I'd you're betraying
probably around 30 to 50 percent there
are a few samples with lower
cellularity x' and this helps us to
better interpret the data once you take
a closer look at the
variants that were called so this isn't
another analysis that it falls firmly
outside of my pipeline but is another
analysis that is really beneficial
particularly in the context of melanoma
after performing SMT detection we can go
in and look at with the actual base
changes what these changes are actually
occurring at each of those variants and
so using the Watson and Crick Watson and
Crick comparing the different
possibilities of base changes are shown
in this figure and you'll see that the
majority of the changes are occurring
from C to T and so it was about 55
percent of all snps that we detected
have a seat at T transition and this is
interesting this is particularly
relevant again from Illinois because in
cutaneous melanoma is well-known that
there is a UV signature associated with
the disease and what this means that is
that over 60% of C decreased CPT
transitions are occurring and die
pyrimidine and so we decide to look at
that in our cohort of April melanoma
although we don't expect to see a UV
signature we thought this would be
relevant to check and so when we did a
corporate level analysis of CDT
transitions only about 39 percent of
those events were occurring in diapered
a meetings to show that there is no UV
signature present at the cohort level
however we also went in to each
individual subject and also performed
this analysis and what was interesting
is that we saw that two patients
actually showed by UV signature in their
tumor and the third patient was trending
towards having a UV signature with about
59 percent of their seeded he
transitions occurring in die pyrimidine
and so this
a bit of a busy slide but it summarizes
a lot of our work from doing the SMB
detection as well as our copy number
analysis and structural variant analysis
so along the bottom you'll see the
patient numbers associated with the
different tumors and across the top
there are on the two bar graphs on top
those show mutation burdens with respect
to coding point mutations for SMBs or
copy number changes as reflected as CNVs
and we also broke these down following
the TCA subtypes that's typically used
to characterize cutaneous melanoma so we
could look in more closely at this and
we'll see that there are 18 percent of
the patients that we sequence showed
some level of B Roth alteration with
respect to interests or K rest mutations
15 percent in shared alterations and
about nine percent showed alterations in
nf1 overall from our entire analysis we
had identified permutations and about we
then fight about 9,500 total point
occations
and 72 small Intel's however looking at
only coding events we identified a
medium of 42 point mutations and what
was interesting that we observed from
this analysis was that there are spore
patients who receive treatments prior to
us sequencing their samples and so they
demonstrated at higher levels of
mutation burdens and so their media
encoding SMBs
were approximately 75 as opposed to 42
and we look at the entire cohort we also
used intogen and music to identify
putative drivers and nerburn our dataset
and so when we did a corporate level
analysis we filmed at Penrice and b raf
were significant putative drivers in
this dataset and what was interesting is
that in the NRS in the patients ahead
and rest events three of them have a
well known activated
k61 communication that is has been
reported in cutaneous melanoma again we
only looking at the kit mutations we
there was actually only one patient who
had a kit alteration and this was
actually a little bit unexpected because
in previous reports it was reported that
11% of male alums have a key alteration
and there's also multiple ways to come
with the data set so we did look at
changes that may be associated
specifically with metastatic status or
whether the tumor was primary or
meditech metastasis we did so we did do
a specific primary only analysis as well
as a meta-analysis following on houses
we found that the RAF was still a
significant Peter - driver in both
cohorts if we did this division um
however what was interesting is that the
mutation Burnham was higher in the Met
met samples as opposed to the primary
samples so looking at copy number
changes from our entire analysis of the
entire data set we identified about 1100
somatic CMBS following this analysis we
performed consensus and houses of Essene
bees so we wanted to see what was the
most recurrently occurring i'm changes
across the entire cohort following Atkin
and this consensus analysis was
performed using gistic - so following
district 2 analysis we denta 548 total
CMBS
of which 40 or deletions and eat
workings and these are summarized here
on this slide and you'll see that some
interesting events that we identified
are include games in TAC 1 and OCD k4 as
well as deletions in cdkn2a at p10 and O
7 of 1 we also did a division of the
sample set into primaries only and
that's only and we observed that in
early primaries the p10 deletion
retained significance and
not only that sample group the empty
there's mdm2 games that were
significance of accurate so moving on to
the structural variant analysis overall
we identified roughly about 2,500
different somatic breakpoints I'm across
31 patients and up 31 patients 74%
demonstrated some form of a structural
variant and so in this graph we
summarized a number of structural
variants that were identified across all
the patients and you'll see that patient
14 don't had a 683 somatic breakpoints
identified and they all fell on
chromosome 12 to show evidence of
chromothripsis for the most part the the
range of value of structural variants
was more heavily around 100 to 200 and
so this is aligned with previous reports
that there is a heavier structural
variant burden and so we also looked at
the most frequently impacted chromosomes
by the somatic breadcrumbs are
identified and we found that and at
least patients with a wild-type b-raf
the most number of structural variants
were found to impact homersim v and
ellen croissant v there's two genes that
were heavily affected and these include
a t cy 2 and c LPT m1l and what was
interesting is that as you see in later
slides we did find increased levels of
changes in current and CLP t1m m1l lies
upstream butchered so another analysis
that we also ran was also assembling our
any leads to see if we can find
supporting RNA data for these
breakpoints that we identified and
looking at the ADC y2 or the CLP TM 1
SDS
we did find that there was a presence of
RNA supporting our new fusions and for
the 6 patients i showed offensive these
genes and so again this sort of
emphasizes the benefit of having both
DNA and RNA level data
and so here I just summarize all the
copy number changes and also structural
variants that were detected across the
entire cohort you'll see that in the
center these are these are the yellow
lines reflect translocations and you'll
see that it is heavily impact in
primarily chromosome five on the lower
right hand corner so we also performed a
sort of a pathway type style of analysis
using the DNA level data and so pulling
out key recurrent pathways that are
commonly reported in melanoma we looked
in these pathways to see if the genes
were mutated over impact in any way in
our cohort and so the left hand side
looking at the survival and
proliferation pathways we found that 66%
of genes in this I'm sorry 66 percent of
patients demonstrate some sort of
alteration in the survival proliferation
pathways and you'll see for the most
part a lot of events are associated with
a game with the exception of p10 and F
and of one who which them are
demonstrating blossom function we also
observed Church alterations in a third
of the patients we also observed changes
in cell cycle progression with 51% of
patients showing alterations in that
pathway and with respect to apoptosis as
in essence we observed changes and 70
Perce 17% of patients so in other
since that in people for him but using
this type of dataset is looking very
beautifully actionable somatic events
and so we did this by going through each
patient's data and seeing if there's
associations with any drugs are
currently available and what was sort of
encouraging was that about over 70% of
patients demonstrated therapeutically
actionable events and some of them are
listed here so for example with the beer
at v600e or B 600k event and possible
therapies that can be considered include
a brand of American had been tremendous
and this is relevant for for patients
the cdkn2a
vocal deletion which was problem across
number of patients can be targeted using
Pablos a power cycling bible cycling or
cbk for six inhibitors so again this is
just another demonstration of the
utility of having this type of data set
and how it can be used to sort of infer
the benefit of sort of precision
medicine type work so again the results
that we found to support the etiology of
maple melanoma and also identified
potentially novel therapeutic options
and again because we have such a large
data set we there are a number different
analyses that a number of different
additional analyses that can be
performed and so another approach we
took to the RNA seek data was that after
pulling out differentially expressed
genes we looked at the top most
differentially expressed genes that
these are about 420 genes and performed
unsupervised clustering of these samples
then james and so the heat map shown
here is the results of his clustering
analysis so you'll see along the bottom
these are at a patient's so there's each
patient corresponds to a different
column the the rows that go horizontally
correspond to specific genes and what
was interesting is that when we cluster
these genes we found that there was five
clusters that broke out and you'll see
these as a red yellow green blue and
purple clusters these clusters are
associated with specific processes
and so you'll see that the red cluster
associated protein translation lab with
simple processes and OSA nonsense
mediated decay and you know you can go
through and see the rest of different um
pathways associated these clusters and
what was also interesting is that we did
see that certain pathways help to
differentiate samples based on whether
they weren't a primary or met and so
you'll see that sort of large chunk down
at the bottom of the heat map where you
see that the majority that metastasis
samples are green and the majority of
the primary samples are red and so this
is really in line that's actually what
has already been reported in continuous
melanoma specifically that keratin genes
in the Mets are down regulated whereas
they are operated in primaries and we
are similarly seeing that here and this
April cohort another analysis that we
also performed in agreeing both RNA and
DNA data is neo antigen analysis and so
this analysis really lets you see the
level to which there are potential and
new peptides that may be expressed as
results of a coding somatic alterations
that was identified through exome
sequencing and so we looked at new
antigen expression across all the
patients as well as HLA expression with
the image the class 1a B or C molecules
and so this is definitely of interest
since there are there's been a sort of a
wave of these of checkpoint inhibitors
and so for our cohort there was twenty
to thirty for patients who received
checkpoint inhibitors and contain E's
melanoma response the checkpoint
inhibitors has been described but this
has been described yet in micro melanoma
and so similar to what we see in
cutaneous melanoma we did see a
correlation between neo antigen burden
as well as the mutation burden we also
wanted to we did a sort of a polymer
analysis looking at the correlation
between mutation neo antigen burden and
a response to checkpoint blockade
unfortunately we don't have enough
patience to power that type of analysis
so we weren't able to to derive a
conclusion from that however there were
three patients are in a cohort who
demonstrated a complete response to
either anti anti PD one or anti ctla4
and interesting they hadn't both lower
mutation and also new management burdens
another interesting result that we found
in her study was the identification of
events impacting pack 1 and so we
observed copy number games as well as
over expression of have one and about
twelve twelve percent of patients and
these patients were mutually exclusive
of those that should be RAF raster nf1
alterations and this has again pop one
has not actually been specifically
implicated in April melanoma and so this
is why we thought it is an interesting
tool effort since it has them to define
as a potential therapeutic and Katinas
melanoma
following our analysis of DNA and RNA
data we also found that there was a
number of different alterations
impacting tert and so in Katinas
melanoma it is well known that there is
a percentage of patients who demonstrate
hotspot mutations in the promoter region
which relates to activation of chart
however this hasn't been specifically
reported in Agra melanoma although one
study did find that 9% of april's did
demonstrate a turret hotspot mutation in
the promoter and so in our analysis we
found that aside from these trip
promoter mutations that were also
simulate identified in nine percent of
our patients there were a range of
different types of events also impacting
her and so we have them summarized here
so we see copy number games impacting
chart we have there's a number of
different break points one point
mutation and we also identified that in
two patients for whom didn't have any
somatic turret alterations they had two
where they had each of them had their
own rare germline snip and hurt
and these events were predicted by a
prediction tool fathom which stands for
the functional analysis through hidden
Markov models it was predicted to be
damaging and something will set a
highlight here is that we did observe
trait expression across all samples the
graph probably doesn't do justice to it
but we do see some level of expression
after across all samples and under
normal conditions we wouldn't expect to
see this and so this is just a
possibility after activation and in many
of the samples and so overall we saw
that 41 percent of the patients
demonstrated some level alter alteration
in their tumor I'm given this finding we
worked with Mayo Clinic in Scottsdale
Arizona to perform some downstream
functional assays to look at the
efficacy of inhibiting tert in a granola
and so we use three different cell lines
the first SMC 0:19 had it
CN be gain and that cell line there was
another cell line and SVTC zeros or one
zero zero two that had a trip promoter
mutation we also use a normal Milano
psych line as a control and so both of
the two equal melanoma lines that we
looked at are derived from actual
patients and so what we did we see used
to omurice inhibitor nine which is a
commercially available inhibitor and
treated each of these cell lines for 72
hours nobody found that using 2.5
microns we did the the treatment of
using the inhibitor resulted in a
decrease over 75% viability and the
April cell lines whereas it did not
highly impact that normal - a sign we
also looked at the expression of terton
mrna
in these cells following treatment with
the Tommies inhibitor and found that
there was there's no expression and no
change in the normal on a site line and
there's decreased expression of tur mrna
and the two April cell lines that are
treated with that one recent emitter and
so the details of all our analyses are
described in our publication and Genome
Research which we publish earlier this
year and so another aspect of our
analysis was that we really understood
the value of being able to share our
data with our collaborators and also
just with the scientific community when
the study was ongoing we did have an
internal instance of cbio portal and we
also had servers that we can use to
easily transfer data between
collaborators and after completion of
the study we have dumped the data into
DB gap so it could be available by other
so it's available for analysis by other
investigators we've also placed our data
on cbio portal so if you go onto the
public website receive are born all
right now we have access to our data and
it's under the melanoma I'm heading so
they'd want to briefly touch upon some
other orthogonal studies that we worked
on as a results and sort of really as a
result of the work we did through our
primary work so based off of our
findings at Turin in addition may be an
effective way to to kill a grown
melanoma cells we did work with dr.
Lawrence really after University of
Arizona and he does a really interesting
work where he's able to develop
inhibitors that specifically target a
motif that occurs in the human genome
and this is the G quadruplex
or G for structure and so this structure
is specifically enriched and promoters
of oncogenes and also in the first the
beginning of the first intron of genes
and as well as in telomeres so he was
able to design a inhibitor that was
found to successfully lock down the trip
promoter inhibitor and in doing so it
can repress turret expression however
removal of this particular inhibitor
cannot revert the expression iturra back
to overexpression so I was able to
regulate for an expression and have you
thought that this is particularly
meaningful approach to potentially
regulate your expression in cells that
are dependent
in addition to the they gave for
quadruplex analysis we also have
collaboration again with Mayo Clinic and
they were developing PDFs from the
samples that production from the samples
are collected from the patients we
sequenced and so they initiated a number
of different models and right now they
have currently 10 models are ready for
testing
and what's really beneficial about this
is that it allows us to do drug
treatments and for their functional
analyses particularly in patients that
may have more of a quiet genome for
example one of the patients did not
demonstrate significant number of
structural variants or even point.you
taejun's
however they did have a mass mutation
and so we can really focus ort of do
analysis in this type of context using
this PDX model so in in terms of current
future directions we do have a study
that was just recently initiated and
this is headed up by dr. will Hendricks
at ijen and dr. Lance cow at Baylor
Scott and White and the goal of the
study is to continue the characterize
that the landscape mature alterations
and mucosal and also April melanomas and
secondary the goal is also to look at
the effect of changing our alterations
on the function of telomerase and we
also want to look at the impact of turin
efficient in both mucosal and ignore
melanoma and so again I want to
emphasize the importance of having a
collaborative model having be given
again that this is data and by formatic
track the the success value and really
the utility of by informatics really
hinges on getting high quality samples
having clinical annotations and doing
comprehensive analysis and so it's the
combination of both clinical clinical
resources as well as by our genetics and
genomics that really is going to drive
our ability to make a translational
impact on patients and so I'd like to
acknowledge a really large team of
scientists who were involved in the
study this was the study was headed up
by dr. Jeffrey Trent
Tejan and as our clinical collaborators
dr. Jeffery sauceman and Charlotte area
and rubella Morrison Kettering Alec
Sekulow at the Mayo Clinic along with
Jessica really spearheaded the charts
online and I'll sees as well as
developing the PDX models Lawrence
Hurley he was a key collaborator for
identifying an approach to potentially
regulate each rate expression and she
youngbae from the Samsung Medical Center
provided one of the equal melanoma cell
lines that we use for analysis and again
this effort was that it culminates as a
result of all the work from a number of
different implementations and scientists
as well and I'd be happy to take any
questions
thank you dr. Liang for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for if we are unable to get
to your question we will follow up with
you via email after the presentation
let's get started our first question is
were you able to use the different X
owned long insert and RNA data set to
validate mutations in our
data set to validate mutation yes great
question and so that really sticks into
the really the benefits of having
multiple sequencing mentalities from the
same samples and so we were able to
validate some of the events specifically
if we look at coding events 12% were
valid tobe 10% of the coding snps
identified their exome sequencing was
validated for your long answer for
genome sequencing I'm noting the fact
that we did have low sequence coverage
lower average sequence coverage of the
long interval genome data however
looking at the same including events 90%
were validated in by the RNA seek data
and so again 90% of the coding evidence
we identified were expressed
great thank you we'll wrap up with one
more question and that question is aside
from the pack one intern findings were
there any additional results that was
striking say yes in addition to the
certain type one findings there were
there was quite a bit of interesting
things that we found one of the as I
mentioned during my presentation was the
identification of a used B signature and
two of the patients which was very
unexpected after reviewing the data with
the clinicians we did sort of realize
that the possibility that I'm needing a
better biomarker for disease because it
is possible that because equal melanomas
most often occur in planta regions or
some protected regions there may be
misdiagnosis where they may actually
reflect a different type of melanoma or
cutaneous no melanoma and so that was
something that was educational for both
for the scientists and clinicians and it
helps us to better understand how we can
better improve through diagnosis for
patients
again thank dr. Liang for her
presentation do you have any final
comment now again I just want to thank
everyone for attending and again I've
mentioned this multiple times during my
talk but again the utility and the
benefit of doing writer dramatics
analysis really require this piece of
high-quality samples and so I hope to
encourage people to continue to
collaborate and work together thank you
once again dr. Liang I would also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January
twelfth two thousand eighteen you will
receive an email some lab routes letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye